[Music]  Kim Kardashian is shutting down the  haters claiming she altered this photo  just to scrutiny that we get all the  time we try to avoid that what Photoshop  failed that's what Kim K is asking after  she posted this Instagram pic in an  orange jacket crop top and spandex  cut-offs on Monday the reality star took  to her app to set the record straight  after fans pointed out the distorted car  in the back saying Kim suffered a major  Photoshop fail she wrote in part so  ridiculous i reposted a picture on  instagram that a fan had already posted  i only added a filter to it adding it  looks like the fan mirrored the pic  which is the reason the car looks like  that while we see what Kim is saying one  fan account called celeb face made a  before-and-after video that seems to  show more than just a filter change  looks like Kim got face tuned happy on  her waist hips and hair I'm so curvy  that if I try to like put other things  on and I look like a joke  you